[Music]
robert
is in colorado springs colorado hey
robert welcome to the dave ramsey show
hi dave hope you're having a good day i
am sir how can we help
well i am let me start by saying i'm a
new listener so i'm not super familiar
with the baby steps
uh but i you know i've been kind of
intrigued about the idea of kind of
eliminating all debt
but my question was really more
revolving around the idea
is there such thing as good debts if the
interest rate is low enough
and you know this is say for example i
have enough cash
to pay off the substantial amount of
debt but that
cash is busy with investments currently
would it be better off to pay off some
low interest debt or
let the you know the money stay with
those investments
and you know they make money in those
investments that is greater than the
interest rates
i guess as a way to describe it it's a
great question and
one that a lot of people have asked over
the years i used to
kind of subscribe to the same thing
because i'm a math nerd and the idea
that
if i could borrow if i if my mortgage
rate is
three percent and i can put money in a
mutual fund and it makes me ten percent
then i made a seven spread why would i
not do that all day long
sure that's the same kind of a thing
that you're saying right
correct yeah so for example you know i
have a business in colorado
yeah and we own a warehouse and so
there's a very big loan against
said warehouse but the interest rate uh
fortunately you know the chronovirus
didn't work out well for this one which
is only two and a half percent
ta-da there we go okay now that's
exactly what i'm coming to
what i discovered uh and you're a new
listener so you don't know the whole
stinking story but
i started buying and selling real estate
in my 20s starting from nothing i had 4
million
worth i was a millionaire when i was 26.
then i lost it all
because the loans got called by the
banks and
my theory of making the spread all went
to kaput because i got zero out of it i
ended up bankrupt at 28
and i got the opportunity to start over
which made me question
my former theories because my former
theory didn't work what i had left out
of my theory
what most people leave out of this
theory that you and i are discussing the
three percent versus the ten percent
mutual fund
the seven percent spread appears to be
there what we leave
out of that theory is risk
sure and mathematically if you install
risk
into the equation it starts to dilute or
do away with the spread
and other types of investments in
sophisticated investment analysis on
for instance an aggressive growth stock
mutual fund compared to a
growth and income stock mutual fund the
aggressive is much more volatile much
more risky
the uh traditional mutual fund the
growth and income is let much less risky
has a lower uh peaks and valleys if you
chart it you follow me
yeah so you would never compare a high
risk volatile fund
rate of return apples to apples
with a lower risk less volatile return
so you might make a 10 on that growth in
income you might make 22 on that
aggressive but you don't compare them
the same because we don't compare the
roulette wheel
with a cd sure we adjust for risk
and what happens in what you're
discussing is we forget to adjust for
risk
so i learned the hard way that risk is
real and people learned it again in 2008
and they learned it again with covid
this year that risk is real
and that when you have debt you are
susceptible to getting your freaking
head taken off
i agree i have my question i guess in
regard to that
and so i consequently decided to be and
live debt free as the shortest path to
becoming and staying wealthy
yeah well i can't go well that way there
is no risk yeah exactly
or very little yeah you know much less
there's other risks but it's not the
banks
you know it we're not going to get
foreclosed on
sure at all now do i buy fewer things
because of that
yeah because it takes more money i don't
have the you know i
don't own as many buildings i own a
bunch own several hundred million
dollars worth of real estate nowadays
but
i you know but that doesn't but i
probably could own
a couple of billion if i leveraged the
same amount of equity into stuff
uh and but then i would be up at night
when covet hits
i'd be up at night when 2008 hits i'd be
up at night when trump gets crossways
with the chinese
i'd be up at night worrying about how
i'm gonna make my freaking payments
because some tenant didn't make theirs
yeah and so life is too short
the shortest path to peace in my
finances
security in my finances i might be
sacrificing some return but i doubt i
really
am at the end of the day because
adjusted for risk i didn't really lose
that much
so i live a hundred percent debt-free so
if you're sitting on some investments
and you could pay off all your debts
i would pay off your debts and then i
would usually increase cash flow to
begin to build some other investments
and not have any debt laying around
because with no payments
you have incredible cash flow with no
payments you have incredible peace
and that's where i came to honor to have
you as a new listener thanks for letting
me discuss that with you